SESSION.
BRET?
>> Bret: CATHERINE HERRIDGE
LIVE ON THE HILL AFTER A LONG
DAY.
LET'S GET REACTION FROM THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM TO THE
COHEN TEAM.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERT
JOHN ROBERTS.
HERE IN VIETNAM TO COVER THE
SUMMIT LEADS OFF WITH A PRETTY
MINIMAL RESPONSE SO FAR.
GOOD MORNING, JOHN.
>> SO FAR THERE'S BEEN NO
RESPONSE OTHER THAN A TWEET HE
SENT OUT WHICH PRECEDED COHEN'S
TESTIMONY IN WHICH THAT COHEN
HAD DONE BAD THINGS UNRELATED TO
TRUMP.
ONE OF THE ATTORNEYS JAY SEKULOW
DID RESPOND TO A PORTION OF
COHEN'S
CHANGED HIS STATEMENT TO ALTER
THE DURATION OF THE TRUMP TOWER
MOSCOW NEGOTIATIONS IS FALSE.
NO QUESTION THAT COHEN'S
TESTIMONY LEFT THE PRESIDENT
FIGHTING TO KEEP HIS SUMMIT WITH
KIM JONG UN AND IN THE NEW
SPOTLIGHT.
>> THE MICHAEL COHEN TESTIMONY
BARGED IN ON HIS SECOND MEETING
WITH KIM JONG UN.
THE PRESIDENT REFUSING TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS FORMER
ATTORNEY.
BUT WE DID GET SOME INSIGHT IN
THE PRESIDENT'S THINKING FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM WHO SPOKE WITH THEM
BEFORE COHEN'S TESTIMONY.
>> IT DID BOTHER HIM THAT THERE
WAS GOING TO BE A SPLIT SCREEN
BETWEEN MICHAEL COHEN AND HIM
WITH KIM JONG UN.
THAT'S JUST THE WORLD YOU LIVE
IN.
>> IN HIS SOCIAL DINNER WITH
HIM, PLAYING HIS CARDS CLOSE TO
HIS VEST.
>> I THINK IT'LL LEAD TO
WONDERFUL -- REALLY A WONDERFUL
SITUATION.
OUR RELATIONSHIP IS A VERY
SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
KIM JONG UN HAVE A SIGNING
CEREMONY SCHEDULED FOR THIS
AFTERNOON.
THE PRESIDENT IS UNDER PRESSURE
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE POLITICAL
AISLE TO MAKE PROGRESS ON KIM'S
PROMISE ON LAST JUNE'S SUMMIT TO
DISMANTLE HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> MY BIGGER WORRIED IS THAT
NORTH KOREA WILL GIVE TOO LITTLE
OR NOTHING, BECAUSE WHAT WE SAW
LAST YEAR IS REALLY NO
COMMITMENT OF ANY SUBSTANCE.
>> IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT THE
PRESIDENT AND KIM WILL SIGN, AND
THE SUBSTANCE OF A DEAL COULD
SHIFT IN TODAY'S MEETING.
IDEAS THAT ARE KICKED AROUND OUR
OPENING LIAISON OFFICES TO
FACILITATE ONGOING DIALOGUE,
CLOSING DOWN THE YONGBAN
FACILITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN TRYING
TO SELL THEM ON THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS HE COULD REAP IF HE
GIVES UP HIS WEAPONS OF MASS
INSTRUCTION AND JOINS THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
>> AS I SAID, I SAID TO THE
PRESS, I SAY TO ANYONE THAT
WANTS TO LISTEN, I SAY THAT YOUR
COUNTRY HAS TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC
POTENTIAL.
UNBELIEVABLE.
UNLIMITED.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WHAT WILL
HAPPEN.
I'M HOPING IT TO HAPPEN.
>> NORTH KOREA EXPERTS TELL
FOX NEWS THAT IT IS UNLIKELY
THAT KIM WILL GIVE UP HIS
NUCLEAR PROGRAM ALL AT ONCE.
THERE IS STILL DEEP DISTRUST OF
THE UNITED STATES IN
NORTH KOREA.
ONE OF THE PRESIDENT'S GOALS
THIS WEEK AND IN HIS ONE-ON-ONE
MEETING LAST NIGHT?
TO BUILD TRUST BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTRIES.
>> WILL PAY FOR THAT DIALOGUE.
>> WE WILL FIND OUT MORE ABOUT
HOW THE SUMMIT WENT AND WHAT THE
TWO LEADERS AGREED TO WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP HOLDS A PRESS
CONFERENCE THIS AFTERNOON.
IT'S ALSO A SAFE BET THAT HE'LL